let's say we have three matrices a B and
C and let's say that B and C are both M
by n matrices and that a is a let's call
it a K by M matrix and what I want to do
is figure out whether matrix products
exhibit the distributive property so
let's test out a times B plus C a times
B plus C and of course these are all
matrices so B just to make things clear
be the matrix B could be represented as
just a bunch of column vectors v1 v2 all
the way to BN and the matrix C can also
be represented as just a bunch of column
vector so could with the matrix a but I
don't have to draw that just yet
so the matrix C could just be
represented as a bunch of column vectors
C 1 C 2 all the way to C and maybe I
should've drawn this taller these are
column vectors so they actually have
some verticality to them I think you've
seen that multiple times so what is a
times B plus C well let's let's figure
out what B plus C is this is equal to a
times B plus C when you add B plus C the
definition of matrix addition is you
just add the corresponding columns which
essentially boils down to adding the
corresponding entries so that is going
to be equal to the first column is going
to be equal to b1 plus c1 the second
column is going to be b2 plus c2 and
you're going to go all the way to the
nth column is going to be BN plus CN now
by our definition of matrix matrix
products this is this product right here
is going to be equal to its going to be
equal to the matrix where we take the
matrix a and multiply it by each of the
column vectors of this matrix here of B
plus C which as you can imagine these
are both M by n in fact they both have
to have the same dimensions for this
addition to be well-defined
so this is going to be an M by n matrix
are you told you that a is a K by
and we know this is well-defined because
a has the same number of columns as B
plus C has a row so this is well-defined
and this is going to be equal to let me
switch colors again it's going to be
equal to a times the column vector b1
plus c1 the second column is going to be
a times the column vector B 2 plus c2
running out of space it's going to be
all the way to a times the column vector
B n plus C n this is our definition of
matrix matrix products you just take the
first matrix and you multiply it times
each of the column vectors of the second
Matrix and we can we can say that
because we've already defined matrix
vector products so what is this thing on
the right equal to I'll keep switching
colors this is equal to we know that
matrix vector products exhibit the
distributive property I don't even
remember when I did that video but we've
assumed it for a while it's a very
trivial thing to prove so this each of
these columns are going to be equal to
let me write it this way this guy right
here can be rewritten the first column
is going to be a time's the column
vector b1 plus a time's the column
vector c1 this term right there is the
same thing as that term right there the
next one is going to be a b2 plus matrix
a time's the vector c2 and then the nth
column is going to be the matrix so we
have keep going and then the nth column
is going to be the matrix a time's the
column vector B n plus matrix a time's
the column vector C C and just like just
like that now we can write this matrix
as the sum of two different matrices so
what is this going to be equal to this
is equal to this is equal to let me see
I'll rest write it right here this is
equal to
a B 1 as the first column a B 2 is the
second column all the way to a B n as a
third column so that's these terms right
there and then if I were to add to that
the matrix a times vector c1 a time's
the column vector c2 these are just the
different columns of this matrix and we
just then have the matrix a time's the
column vector C n these represent these
terms so clearly if I add these two
matrices I just add the corresponding
column vectors and I'll get this matrix
up here but what is this equal to this
this right here by definition this is
the matrix a times the matrix B right
the definition of matrix products is you
take the first matrix and multiply times
the column vectors of the second Matrix
and by the same argument I guess you
could say this is equivalent to a times
C and all of this remember we just got a
bunch of equal signs is equal to a times
B plus C so now we can say definitively
that as long as the products are
well-defined and the sums are
well-defined so they all have to have
the correct dimensions that a times B
plus C is equal to a B plus a C so it
matrix products do exhibit the
distributive property at least in this
direction and I say that because
remember matrix products are not
commutative so we don't know necessarily
that B plus C times a is equivalent to
that in fact most of the times these two
things are not equivalent so we don't
know quite yet that if we reversed this
whether it's still going to exhibit the
distributive property so let's try to do
that let's do that I'll do a little bit
quicker because I think you know the
general argument here so let's take B
plus C times a and I'll just write a is
its column vectors a1 a2 all the way to
a has m columns if I remember correct
right a has m columns so all the way to
a M and by the definition of matrix
products this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to the matrix
B plus C is just a matrix right we can
represent it as a sum of two matrix but
this is just a matrix so it's B plus C
times each of the column vectors of a so
it's going to be equal to B plus C times
a 1 B plus C times a 2 all the way to B
plus C times a n and I once again I've
many videos ago that I think we showed
that the mate that matrix vector
products are distributive that they are
distributive so we can just distribute
this vector along these two matrices and
if I haven't proven it yet it's actually
a very straightforward proof to do so we
could say that this is equal to this is
equal to B a 1 plus C a 2 that's the
first column the second column is B
times a 2 plus C times a 2 all the way
to B times a n plus C times a n plus C
times a n and then what is this equal to
well I think we can skip well I'll write
it out this is equivalent to B times a
this is a one oh this is an A one right
here B times a 1 and then B times a 2
all the way to be a n plus the vector C
times a1 C times a 2 all the way to C
times a n right this guy represents
these terms right there this guy
represents the first terms in each of
these column vectors and this by the
definition of matrix products is just
equivalent to be a and then this is just
equivalent to ca
so now we've seen that the distributive
property works both ways with matrix
matrix vector products that b plus c
times a is equal to b a plus C a and
that a times B plus C a times B plus C
is equal to a B plus a C now the one
thing that you have to be careful of is
that these two things are not equivalent
or you just figured out that this guy is
equal to B a plus C a so the
distribution works in both ways but when
you're dealing with matrices it's very
important to keep order to keep your
order so that this is going to be you
know you have the a second here so it's
be a plus C a you can't say that this is
equal to a B plus AC you can't just
switch these up because we've shown
multiple times or we've talked about it
multiple times that matrix products are
not commutative you can't just switch
the order of the products but we've at
least shown in this video that the
distributive property works both ways